في ظل ازمه امدادات الطاقه التي تعصف
باوروبا جراء حرب اوكرانيا القاره العجوز
تواصل جهودها الحثيثه بحثا عن مصادر جديده
للطاقات بعيدا عن عباءه روسيا قاده المجر
ورومانيا وجورجيا واذربيجان توصلوا الى
اتفاق بشان خط توصيل كهرباء تحتميه البحر
الاتفاق يتضمن تركيب خط يمر بالبحر الاسود
ليربط اذربيجان بالمجر عبر جورجيا
ورومانيا لتصدير الكهرباء من مزارع الرياح
البحريه الى اوروبا
الخطوه تاتي في وقت تسعى فيه المجر التي
عارضت بشده عقوبات الاتحاد الاوروبي على
روسيا للتواصل لمصادر اضافيه من الوقود
الاحفوري بهدف تقليل اعتمادها الشديد على
النفط والغاز الروسي المشروع يرمي الى
تنويع امدادات الطاقه وزياده امن طاقه
الاقليمي وفق بيان صادر عن الاطراف
شركه انتاج الغاز الطبيعي الرومانيه قالت
انها وقعت عقدا مع شركه النفط الحكوميه في
اذربيجان لتلقي الغاز الطبيعي عبر ما يسمى
بممر الغازي الجنوبي ومن المقرر ان تبدا
عمليات التسليم في الفاتح من يناير المقبل
هي خطوه لتنويع مصادر الطاقه في اوروبا في
ظل فصل الشتاء البارد واستمرار الحرب في
اوكرانيا وازمه العلاقات مع موسكو التي
تبدو بلا افق حتى الان
بلال
العربي العربيه